blumenthal speaks at communist party
award ceremony this is a washington free
beacon senator richard blumenthal
democrat from connecticut spoke at an
award ceremony over the weekend hosted
by a communist party affiliate whose
leaders use the event to recruit
potential members to members of the
organization blumenthal won the
wealthiest members of the senate
presented certificates of special
recognition from the senate to three
winners of the amistad award given
annually by the connecticut people's
world committee affiliate of the uh
communist party usa in the marxist
people world news site blumenthal was
introduced at the event by lisa
bergman a communist party member who
blamed corporations for imperialism that
exists in our world that is undermining
the labor environment
if you are not part of the communist
party we invite you to participate and
contribute and join bergman said after
blumenthal's speech there's more and
more people talking about socialism in
this country as it becomes more and more
clear that capitalism is not going to
work for our future
thoughts on that thomas
um well you have to remember can you
pull up blumenthal just pull up
blumenthal
capitalism builds the engine that is
running for taxes that
socialism uses because you cannot
perpetually print money otherwise you
end up like greece
you know what in 1980 1990
this guy did this
can you imagine the uproar remember the
anti-communist sentiment that was back
there and this guy had done this
15 years ago 25 years ago it would be
political death
it should be is he up for re-election
next year curious now take a look at the
picture he's up for embalming
that's the most disturbing story in our
whole portfolio here today this one i
mean this one really pisses me off how
this guy can actually show his face
there and do this by the way he's worth
100 million you know where the money
comes from his wife his wife it's all
real estate holdings by the way they own
part of the empire state building i know
that's part of their their ownership
stake is it's part of their wealth is
owning the empire state building do you
know who he beat just to become a
senator you know he beat he'd be uh
vince mcmahon's wife remember when she
ran linda mcmahon mcmahon back in 2010
so if we should have gone with the wwe
character back then we'd be in a much
better place but how can he do this how
how is he not just kicked out of the
senate this is unbelievable that he
would show his face here or be active
with this shocking i'm really shocked
because i literally i'm not being
inflammatory here you go back 25 years
you go back 15 years this guy would be
on the headlines of every news and would
have just been political death did you
see kevin o'leary and bill maher did you
see bill maher and kevin o'leary
together on the show can you pull up the
transcript kevin uh kevin o'leary and
bill maher so he went up there and bill
maher okay
who is a
liberal
talks about capitalism
yeah exactly just that's plenty buddy
just type in capitalism it'll come up uh
uh
bill maher bill
these people uh uh uh sharkno's bill
maher workers are never i wanna show the
video i'm just worried if it's gonna
stay up or not that's the biggest
concern if it would stay up 28 seconds
if you don't understand click on that
real quick click on that real quick is
it their youtube channel or is it
twitter
uh
[Music]
yeah we probably can't show that so you
may want to pause it so anyways they
they talk to each other bill maher says
i'm a capitalist capitalism works
capitalism has been the system that's
helped america get to where we are today
so
then you get communism a speaker like
that speaks out of communism i wonder
what cnn is saying about blumenthal has
cnn said anything has msnbc said
anything interesting yeah because
there's got to be something we're all
together on
and cnn is shifting i mean see right now
cnn is shifting not centrists but
they're moving off of hard left in some
of their news coverage you hear it you
see it on the white house you see it on
kamala harris you hear it on saturn saki
so there's something inside cnn that's
turning the dial from 11 down to about
eight yeah
i totally agree yeah and so jake tapper
i want to hear one of those kind of pick
up on this
you want to hear what he says no i want
to hear one of these mainstream news
bits kind of call out these things and
talk about it look omarova stepped down
i mean look look
the strange thing about what blumenthal
did is that the winds of change have
already blown
virginia's happened it's in the history
books
and you know to to continue to insist
that this is gonna
i like what you said earlier
let's just sit back eat popcorn pop open
a beer and watch the left side of the
democratic party rip itself apart it's
in a civil war right now okay so check
this out i just typed in blumenthal
type in blumenthal communist party and
then go to news
okay
right just leave okay go go go to all
first go to offers well there's the post
okay
new york post okay i got it that's going
to be on one side fox news fine yankee
institute fine
national review there you go good
so let's see how national review puts it
go on national review go on national
review
send will not deliver switch communist
party let's see how they ride it how
they award it keep going up so every
time when one of us delivered a speech i
don't wear some cameras about it
bloomington antenna event
which was used in part to recruit new
members of our organization presented
certainly
you know the communist party is
affiliated commerce part okay keep going
a little higher keep going a little
higher i'm really excited about honor to
be with you today and sharing this
remarkable occasion blumenthal uses a
special general president biden's bill
back better agenda and democratization
including fifteen dollars
the connecticut democratic consultant
gentlemen holding corporations
accountable bloomberg was invited with
communist party and ceremonial person if
you are not already pocket i mean
there's nothing bad everybody's ready
blue menthol is worth 100 million
dollars largely because of his wife who
is a member of the new york real estate
dynasty he has come under fire for being
unaware of all of his investments
including in the u.s shanghai llc real
estate company connected to chinese
government according to washington free
beacon go a little lower go a little
lower
call it lower okay yeah i mean look if
if you again if you guys are not on the
same page about communism not being this
this was already addressed 50 years ago
you thought you thought this was over
with yeah exactly this is political
treason if you ask me i mean to go out
there and support communism like this
and you asked if he's up for a
re-election he was elected in 2010 so he
will be up in 2022 every six years
a citizen of the state of connecticut
maybe he's out thinking all of us and
he's making himself such an unattractive
candidate to make sure that it flips in
connecticut and you get republican in
there so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]